Speaker 1: All right, after that wacky Trumpist
interlude with Darlene Sofer, let's get into
the last component of this dystopian rally
over the weekend, the attendees, the people
who went into the Trump rally because remember,
without followers, the movement is nothing.
Here is a woman who started crying.
She started crying because she misses Trump.
So much of this country.
Speaker 3: Trump loves this country.
I love my country.
We need to straighten this country up.
I have children and we need.
We need you, Trump.
Our country is going.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree with you.
I'm gonna give you a hug me.
And this is why this is why we do this with
people like you because we know how important
it is for.
We knew we love this country and we know exactly
Speaker 1: this is more sad than anything
else.
I mean, you know, crying because Trump was
president makes more sense, like crying because
it's it was such a terrible.
A terrible episode in this country is like
that would make sense, you know, it was horrible,
it was absolutely humiliating, globally crying
because you want the guy back so bad that
is just very, very strange.
Then they interviewed another woman who said
she's planning to cry when Trump comes out
on stage.
Speaker 2: So what's your anticipation for
today?
I mean, you've got thousands of people here.
You've got Mike Lindell behind us that he's
going to walk out on that on that platform
is just going to be exciting.
Speaker 3: It's I will probably cry when I
see him and everybody else.
This is very emotional because we're finally
people are finally waking up to what happened
in 2020.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree.
It's a very emotional U.S. thing.
It's a very emotional experience.
When he walks around the state is I was in
Washington, D.C., and that was amazing.
On which day on January six, the ellipse?
Yeah, that was merely
Speaker 1: what a great day that was.
That was an amazing day.
This is a cult leader, guys.
This it's it's sounding more and more like
the cultists you read about when you read
about Charles Manson.
When you read about the People's Temple, the
same woman was asked why she likes Trump.
Listen to what she says.
It's the opposite of what's true.
Speaker 2: Why do you love President Trump?
Speaker 3: Well, he's honest.
Speaker 1: He's the biggest liar in the history
of American presidents.
Undeniable fact.
He's a Christian.
He's obviously not a Christian.
He doesn't know anything about the Bible.
He didn't go to church.
He concocted that to trick people like this
woman, and it worked.
That's why he did it, because it worked.
The proof is in the pudding.
This woman believed it
Speaker 3: is
Speaker 1: anti-abortion.
He's not anti-abortion.
He was in favor of choice until he was sixty
eight.
He decided to run and said, I got to come
up with some story about why I'm against abortion.
And he came up with.
I met a kid I liked and the mom told me she
once thought about on abortion, and from that
day forward, I was.
And that happened when he was six eight.
They've fallen for all of it.
Speaker 3: And he calls it like it is.
He says, what all of us are thinking, if we're
Speaker 1: all thinking the things Trump says,
we're screwed.
We're really screwed.
Then they spoke to some guy who's running
for school board on an anti critical race
theory platform.
Speaker 2: No, no CRT, right?
No CRT CRT.
Matter of fact, this one is to if you have
two X chromosomes, you are a white female.
Yes.
Come on, people.
Biology one on one.
Speaker 1: The funniest part is this is not
the crowd that knows about biology, you know?
If I don't want to belabor that, but if you're
trying to ask chromosomal or genetic questions,
the people waiting to go to the Trump rally,
I'm sorry, guys are not exactly the people
that you ask.
OK, then I can't due to too much of this.
But let's go to a woman who also explained,
I guess why she loves Trump.
Speaker 2: Say about it You love your Trump
number one reason why you love President Trump
is why he's going to save America.
And he loves us.
Speaker 3: He absolutely loves
Speaker 1: us.
You know what's really funny and sad about
that?
One of the things we've learned is Trump doesn't
love these people.
Trump's followers are the people he spent
his life trying to stay away from.
And if they are useful to him voting wise,
he'll pretend to like them.
And if they're useful donor wise, he'll pretend
to like them.
But then he'll abandon them.
He'll screw them health, scammed them.
And you know what?
If he runs in twenty four, he'll pretend to
like them again, but they've fallen for all
of it.
Last one, this one.
You can't even come up with an introduction
to this one.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump, you know he's the
modern day Muhammad Ali.
Yes, sir.
Thing like he's going to hit harder next time
right here.
Speaker 1: The only similarity I can think
of between Trump and Muhammad Ali is both
figured out ways not to go to Vietnam, albeit
for very different reasons.
Muhammad Ali, because he was an objector and
Trump because he was a guest scared and claimed
to have bone spurs.
So that's that's the only thing I can think
of.
Very scary stuff.
These people vote, which means we have
to vote.